[Musik]
MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
MURAT: [Jubel] Herzlich willkommen zu Murats 5 Minuten.
Heute gibt’s wieder ein geniales Rezept.
Es nennt sich Upside Down Pizza.
Es ist eine ganz andere Art von Pizza.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe es noch nie gemacht.
Ich werde es auch nicht allein machen.
[Trommelwirbel] Ich habe einen ganz tollen Gast bei mir.
Das Seuchenministerium in Wuhan kennt ihn,
der Tiermarkt in Wuhan kennt ihn [Güni lacht],
die WTO kennt ihn auch.
Bill Gates kennt ihn auch.
Hier: euer Güni. So. Genau. [Jubel]
Heute ist Güni wieder dabei,
mit dem wir jetzt etwas Cooles backen werden.
Wir waren die letzten Tage auf der Baustelle.
GÜNI: [Doing] Du nicht. Du warst im Baumarkt.
MURAT: Nein, ich war nicht im Baumarkt. Ich war auch auf der Baustelle.
Das Ding ist einfach:
Die Sally macht gerade eine Synchronisation eines Kinofilmes,
nämlich Baby Boss.
Deswegen machen wir heute ihre Rezepte.
Der Güni war übrigens auch 10 Jahre lang
Synchronsprecher für Stummfilme – jahrelang. [Güni lacht]
Sie haben es nicht gemerkt, sie haben es nicht gemerkt…
Hast du schon einmal so eine Upside Down Pizza gemacht?
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Nein? War mir klar.
[Beide lachen, Tusch]
Okay. Auf jeden Fall fangen wir zuerst mit dem Teig an.
Wir machen den Sally Pizzateig, den eigentlich jeder schon kennt.
Der ist sehr, sehr easy und einfach.
Deswegen werden wir euch nun einmal die Zutaten vorstellen.
Dann haben wir hier 125 ml Wasser, 250 g Mehl,
10 g Hefewürfel – das ist ungefähr 1/4 Hefewürfel -,
1 EL Zucker, 1 TL Salz und 2 EL Olivenöl. [Güni lacht]
Ja genau. So, das haben wir. Perfekt. Wahnsinn, oder?
[Güni pfeift] Jetzt machen wir unseren… ja. [Lacht]
[Güni lacht]
Du bist so blöd. Du bist so dumm.
Davon könnten 10 Leute blöd werden, gell? Das gibt’s doch nicht!
Du bringst mich durcheinander.
GÜNI: Auch nicht so… Ding, Ding…
MURAT: Nein, nein. Okay. So.
Was machen wir jetzt?
GÜNI: Jetzt alles da rein.
MURAT: Ja mach!
Ich? Ich kann nicht. Ich habe mir den Finger geschnitten.
Ja, ich habe mir heute…
GÜNI: Hat arg weh getan?
MURAT: Ja, furchtbar.
Geil.
Okay. Alles klar. Dann machen wir zuerst das hier rein.
Nein, nicht das Mehl.
GÜNI: Doch.
MURAT: Nein, erst Wasser.
GÜNI: Nein, erst das Mehl.
MURAT: Nein, erst Wasser. Nein, doch, Wasser!
GÜNI: Nein!
MURAT: Wasser!
GÜNI: Nein, dann klumpt das Öl, äh, Mehl. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Ja, du kriegst hin, dass das Öl verklumpt, gell?
Wir machen zuerst das Wasser rein. Ich sage dir auch, warum. Weil…
GÜNI: Warum?
MURAT: Und dann die Hefe rein, genau, dass die Hefe im Wasser aufgeht.
GÜNI: Und Zucker.
MURAT: Hast du reingetan? Und jetzt machst du den…
GÜNI: Zucker rein.
MURAT: Zucker rein, genau! Dass die Hefe Nährstoffe bekommt.
Jetzt rühren wir ein bisschen um. [Doing]
Nein, mit der Maschine.
GÜNI: Aah!
MURAT: Hast du das schon mal gemacht?
GÜNI: Halt, das fällt ab.
MURAT: So, jetzt haben wir das alles drin.
Jetzt tun wir es nur ein bisschen…
[Rührgeräusche]
So. Siehst du?
[Musik]
So, jetzt das Mehl.
[Beide lachen]
Was habe ich jetzt reingemacht? Was war das?
GÜNI: Salz!
MURAT: Salz. Okay, Salz!
GÜNI: Jetzt machen wir das Ding runter und lassen rühren.
MURAT: Ja.
So. On, off. Oh.
Hast du schon mal damit gearbeitet? [Güni lacht]
Ehrlich nicht?
Ja, ich habe nicht damit…
GÜNI: Musst du kennen.
MURAT: Warte kurz. Ich kriege das schon hin.
So, Drehregler und jetzt zum Starten drücken.
Oh, siehst du?
[Küchenmaschine]
Wahnsinn! Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich kann es aber auch schneller machen.
Nein. [Güni lacht]
Ah, wir sind im manuellen Modus.
Und jetzt kneten wir einfach den Hefeteig.
GÜNI: Lassen…
MURAT: Lassen… ja!
Wir könnten es auch selber mit unseren Händen machen.
Aber wir möchten nicht, dass eine Pandemie ausbricht.
Deswegen machen wir es in der Küchenmaschine.
[Küchenmaschine]
Aha! So. Jetzt lassen wir gerade den Pizzateig für 5-10 Min. kneten.
Also 8 Minuten lassen wir ihn kneten.
GÜNI: 7,5 Min.
MURAT: Ja, 7,5 Min. Stimmt! Oh, jawoll!
Gut, ungefähr 7,5 Min. Genau. Währenddessen räumen wir auf.
[Musik und Uhr]
Der Pizzateig ist geknetet, wirklich 8,5 Min., und jetzt muss man -
GÜNI: 7,5 Min.!
MURAT: 7,5 Min.! Tschuldigung! [Beide lachen]
Danke schön, Güni.
GÜNI: Die Hälfte zwischen 5 und 10, ne? [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Ja okay, dann hören wir das jetzt auch schon durch.
Ähm, ja. Jetzt lassen wir den Pizzateig ein bisschen ruhen.
Der soll noch ein bisschen aufgehen.
Also mindestens eine halbe Stunde müsst ihr ihn ruhen lassen.
Hier haben wir die Funktion – darf ich da kurz durch? [Beide lachen]
Hier haben wir die Funktion: Man kann auf Temperatur gehen.
Jetzt gehe ich auf ungefähr 25°C. Jetzt geht er auch besser auf.
Wie gesagt, ungefähr eine halbe Stunde.
Der Güni ist 55 Jahre lang aufgegangen und man sieht:
Es hat schon was gebracht.
GÜNI: Joa! [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Während der Teig eine halbe Stunde aufgeht,
bereiten wir alles vor.
Beim Belag ist wirklich eurer, eurer…
GÜNI: Fantasie!
MURAT: … Fantasie keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt.
Genau, ihr könnt auch jeden Käse benutzen, den ihr wollt.
Also wir haben hier z.B. Gouda Käse, Block-Mozzarella
und wir haben hier einen ganz besonderen Käse:
Scarmoza heißt er. Das ist so ein Weichkäse,
der leicht geräuchert riecht.
Wenn ich jetzt einmal die Form von dem Käse anschaue
und die Form vom Güni…
Das könnte auch der Güni-Käse sein.
GÜNI: Nein, nein, nein, nein!
MURAT: Der Wahnsinn, oder? [Güni verneint]
Doch, der sieht aus wie du.
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Doch,
GÜNI: Das kann nicht sein.
MURAT: Kleiner Kopf, großer Bauch – so! Jetzt bist du…
GÜNI: Und du bist dann großer Kopf, kleiner Bauch? [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Dann reiben wir einfach den Käse. Wir reiben ihn hier her.
Güni, pass auf: Wir machen einfach zwei getrennte Bretter, okay?
GÜNI: Ja.
MURAT: Wie in der Ehe auch: 2 getrennte Betten.
GÜNI: Dann noch so Scheiben dazwischen. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Normalerweise sind es bei einem alten Ehepaar
2 getrennte Betten und bei uns sind es 2 getrennte Bretter.
GÜNI: Ich übernehme das Gemüse.
MURAT: Nimm du die Zwiebeln, Güni!
GÜNI: Ach so? Dass ich weine? [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Ja, genau.
Dann nehme ich den Käse. Und zwar tun wir ihn einfach…
Das Typische für den Käse ist diese Birnenform.
Da schneiden wir einfach den Kopf weg.
[Quietschgeräusche]
[Murat lacht]
GÜNI: Willst du nicht zusammenlassen?
MURAT: Nein.
Kannst du besser reiben.
GÜNI: Ah, stimmt!
Wenn er groß ist.
MURAT: Ah, stimmt! Ich bin so komisch.
GÜNI: „Ich bin so komisch.“ [Lacht]
MURAT: Dann schneidest du die Zwiebeln und ich reibe den Käse.
Ich hatte da wirklich eine Verletzung.
GÜNI: [Entsetzt] So schlimm?
MURAT: Ja, wirklich! Ganz schlimm! [Güni lacht]
Ich hatte da wirklich eine Verletzung.
Jetzt reibe ich diesen Käse. Das Coole ist:
Wenn du den Käse reibst, dann schmilzt er auch schneller.
Nehmt am besten keinen schon fertig geriebenen Käse.
Meistens sind Trennmittel drin. Wusstest du das?
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Weißt du, wofür Trennmittel oft benutzt werden?
Quarz.
[Modemgeräusche]
[Güni lacht]
War das dein Ernst jetzt?
GÜNI: Doch.
MURAT: Ding… Mehl…
GÜNI: Paraffin.
MURAT: Sägemehl… Paraffin ist ein Abfallstoff von Benzin.
Wo sind wir? Bei Jeopardy jetzt, dass du alles raushauen darfst? [Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Wenn du mich so blöd anguckst.
MURAT: Ich gucke dich nicht blöd an.
GÜNI: Doch! Da kommen immer so Sachen aus meinem Mund raus.
MURAT: Aha.
Beim Käse kommt es darauf an, worauf ihr Bock habt.
Also wie viel Käse ihr verwenden wollt.
Ich mag es einfach – mindestens 3 Käsesorten.
Das ist richtig lecker! Ich mag z.B. …
wie heißt der Schimmelkäse nochmal? Dieser…
GÜNI: Gorgonzola.
MURAT: Gorgonzola, genau!
Ich mag z.B. den Tilsiter. Kennst du den?
GÜNI: Du bist in einem Gorgonzola-Fass aufgewachsen, oder? Groß geworden.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Ich habe immer Angst, dass ich dann meine Finger mit reibe.
GÜNI: Bleib mal lieber über dem Teller.
Da ist viel Käse außenherum.
Auf dem Boden kann man wieder aufheben und dazu schmeißen.
Das merkt keiner.
MURAT: Wusstest du, dass wenn du dein Kopf an die Herdplatte hebst
und sie heiß ist, dann kann man hören, wie blöd du eigentlich bist.
GÜNI: Ja?
MURAT: Ja! [Beide lachen]
GÜNI: Mach du mal!
1/2 cm?
MURAT: Ja. Cool.
[Musik]
Jetzt haben wir auch den Gouda verwendet.
Jetzt nehmen wir noch Mozzarella.
GÜNI: Den kann man in Scheiben schneiden.
MURAT: Ah, genau. Den schneiden wir in Scheiben. Hast recht!
Hast du schon mal so einen Block Mozzarella probiert?
Der riecht voll nach Basilikum.
GÜNI: Ja, weil der die ganze Zeit hier lag. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Sehr witzig, ja! [Güni lacht]
Du hast ihn reingelegt, gell?
GÜNI: Leg dich da mal rein. [Lacht]
MURAT: Den Mozzarella schneiden wir wirklich in Scheiben.
[Musik]
Während der Hefeteig noch aufgeht,
bereiten wir auch gleich die Tomatensauce für die Pizza zu.
Die machen wir ganz, ganz easy. Da nehmen wir 400 g Tomatenpüree,
50 g Tomatenmark (dreifach konzentriert), 1 Knoblauchzehe,
1 TL Zucker…
… bisschen Pfeffer
und ein bisschen Oregano, Basilikum oder Thymian – was ihr habt.
GÜNI: Je nach Geschmack.
MURAT: Je nach Geschmack, genau!
Salz und Pfeffer zum Abschmecken.
Diese Sauce heizen wir jetzt erstmal hier
- ups, der ist ja schon warm -
richtig auf. Dafür nehmen wir ein bisschen Olivenöl
– so viel, wie ihr wöllt, wollt! So viel, wie ihr wollt.
[Lacht] So viel, wie ihr "wöllt".
Dann nehmen wir hier…
GÜNI: Ich kann nicht mehr!
MURAT: … die… was ist das, Güni? Die Knoblauchzehe, genau!
GÜNI: Du bist ganz schön geschickt mit deinen langen Fingern.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Ich habe früher oft bei Kurzfilmen mitgespielt, gell?
GÜNI: Du hast doch studiert – Kleinkriminalität. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Den zerschneiden/zerhacken wir hier.
GÜNI: Soll ich festhalten.
MURAT: Nein, ist okay. [Güni lacht]
Jetzt erzeugen wir ein kleines bisschen ein rauchiges Aroma.
GÜNI: Was? Rauchig?!
MURAT: [Mit Überzeugung] Ja!
GÜNI: Knoblauchzehe?
MURAT: Nein, nicht die Knoblauchzehe.
Pass auf, ich zeig's dir gleich, wie es gemacht wird.
Ich weiß, dass du das nicht weißt, da du das noch nie gemacht hat.
Kannst du mir einen Löffel oder Teigschaber geben, Güni?
Jetzt nehmen wir das Tomatenmark
und braten es mit der Knoblauchzehe an.
Das riecht jetzt so richtig buttrig, gell?
Riechst du das?
Achtung, nicht zu viel!
GÜNI: Ich rieche nur Knoblauch.
MURAT: Du riechst alles weg.
GÜNI: Pfeffer oder Chili?
MURAT: Chili oder Pfeffer – wie du es möchtest.
GÜNI: Rein?
MURAT: Ja. Danke schön!
Bitte schön!
Du bist so ein lieber Mensch. Weißt du das? [Güni bejaht]
Ja, du bist so wundervoll.
GÜNI: Halt, den Zucker brauchen wir noch zum Karamellisieren.
Na, gib mal Gas!
MURAT: Warte kurz!
Okay? [Güni stimmt zu]
GÜNI: Warte! Warst du wieder im Druck? [Murat verneint] [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Wahnsinn. Du bist echt so ein toller Mensch, Güni.
Du bist so toll.
Sogar mein Essen kommt hoch und muss dich zu sehen. [Beide lachen]
Jetzt kommt Oregano, Thymian und Basilikum. Komm!
GÜNI: Du bist schon gebildet.
MURAT: Ja? Hast du auch gemerkt?
GÜNI: Ja, ich bin perplex.
MURAT: Überrascht, gell?
GÜNI: Ja, und perplex.
MURAT: Es muss noch Öl rein.
Ach ja. Du hast recht. Was mache ich nur ohne dich?
GÜNI: Oder von deinem Tee kannst du auch reinmachen.
Hauptsache schwarzen Tee reinmachen. [Murat lacht]
MURAT: Ich habe meiner Frau gesagt…
GÜNI: Was hast du gesagt?
MURAT: Ich will nicht etwas mit ihm machen.
GÜNI: Ich will auch lieber mit der Sally kochen.
MURAT: Ja, das glaube ich dir.
So, komm, das machen wir auch noch mit rein.
[Musik]
Basilikum, das ich vorher geschnitten habe, frisch.
Weißt du, warum ich das jetzt gemacht habe?
GÜNI: Dass der Geschmack übernommen wird.
MURAT: Nicht, ich weiß auch nicht, warum. [Beide lachen]
GÜNI: Das habe ich mir gedacht.
MURAT: So, okay? Genau.
GÜNI: Mach mal raus!
MURAT: Darf ich ganz kurz?
GÜNI: Du kannst ja freundlich sein. [Murat stimmt zu]
„Darf ich ganz kurz?“
MURAT: Ja, Entschuldigung.
Vor der Kamera versuche immer nett zu dir zu sein, wirklich!
Ja. Jetzt lassen wir die Sauce ein bisschen köcheln
und schmecken ein bisschen mit Salz und Pfeffer ab
- aus den GEFU Mühlen CYCLONE.
GÜNI: CYCLONE? [Murat bejaht]
Mach noch weiter Pfeffer rein, dann… hält.
MURAT: Okay, jetzt lassen wir es auf mittlerer Stufe ein bisschen köcheln.
Es soll richtig einziehen, dass sich die ganzen Gewürze entfalten.
Dass Oregano… Was haben wir schon reingemacht? Oregano?
Dass es einzieht – genau!
GÜNI: Wo reinzieht? In die Tomate?
MURAT: In mich, Güni! In mich soll es reinziehen! In mich!
Natürlich in die Tomatensoße. [Beide lachen]
So so! [Beide lachen]
GÜNI: Ich kann nicht mehr. Ich kann nicht mehr.
MURAT: Okay, jetzt machen wir weiter.
Jetzt brauchen wir eine kleine Pfanne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diese rechteckige Pfanne habt.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch eine runde Pfanne.
Wir haben hier nur eine rechteckige Pfanne
wegen der Produktplatzierung. Deswegen… [Lacht]
Jetzt nehmen wir ein bisschen Backtrennspray.
GÜNI: Nein, die ist schon eingefettet.
MURAT: Echt? [Güni bejaht]
Ach, das haben wir gar nicht gezeigt.
Wir fetten sie einfach nur ein – so!
[Doing] Was soll ich sagen?
Nein, nein, nein…
Dann haben wir sie eingefettet.
GÜNI: Ich habe deine Technik bewundert.
MURAT: Das war immer in der ersten Klasse:
Ich wurde eingeschult und er wurde eingefettet. [Beide lachen]
Oh. Aua! Das tut voll weh! Sei doch nicht immer so grob! [Beide lachen]
Okay, so. Was wir jetzt machen, ist:
Alle Zutaten, die wir nachher für den Belag benutzen,
braten wir jetzt hier drin an.
Da fangen wir an, die Zwiebeln zu rösten.
[Musik]
GÜNI: Der ist doch wie der, ja?
MURAT: Nein, du hast einen kleineren Löffel.
Siehst du das? Meiner…
GÜNI: Ja, ja. Andersrum, andersrum. So!
[Musik] [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Weißt du, dass die meisten unserer Zuschauer eigentlich
die Männer der Frauen sind, die normalerweise die Videos anschauen?
Es sind meistens die Männer der zuschauenden Frauen.
Wirklich, ohne Spaß!
Weil die Frauen sich denken: Wir blöd kann man sein? [Beide lachen]
Und die Männer sagen: Ja, warum denn nicht?
GÜNI: Genau wie du.
MURAT: Genau. [Ironisch] Die sind genau so dumm wie ich. [Lacht]
GÜNI: Du bist ein bisschen dümmer.
MURAT: Meinst du?
GÜNI: Ich glaube, du bist… [Lacht]
MURAT: Als wie wer?
GÜNI: Mach ein bisschen Öl rein.
MURAT: Ja, aber du weißt, dass es da teure Öl ist.
Wir müssen sparsam damit umgehen.
GÜNI: Mach halt rein. Ich muss ja nicht bezahlen.
Guck, wie das brutzelt – oh!
MURAT: So, das Coole ist jetzt: Wenn ihr so eine Pizza isst und ich will…
GÜNI: Esst!
MURAT: Esst, ja – Tschuldigung. Isst? Esst?
So, wenn ihr die Pizza esst, dann finde ich es immer komisch,
wenn die Zwiebeln so ein bisschen lätschig sind,
aber hier sind sie richtig gut angebraten
und haben ein richtig tolles Röstaroma.
GÜNI: Was sind sie? Lätschig?
MURAT: Lätschig heißt es auf Schwäbisch – lätschig!
Das ist ein neues Werkzeug. Ist zwar pink, aber trotzdem.
Guck!
GÜNI: Steht dir. Es passt zu deiner Schürze. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: So.
GÜNI: Teller? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Richtig schön glasig.
GÜNI: Ja, was jetzt? Gerade eben war es lätschig.
MURAT: Glasig heißt halt…
Ach, ich habe das mal im Kochstudio gehört.
GÜNI: Ach so. [Lacht]
MURAT: So, okay. Das reicht, Günther.
So, jetzt machen wir…
Und jetzt noch die Paprika rein.
[Bratgeräusche]
GÜNI: Tun wir eigentlich noch grüne Paprika rein?
MURAT: Wird ganz schön teuer mit dem Olivenöl, gell?
[Musik und Bratgeräusche]
Ich sortiere sie nach Farbe.
Da hättest du schon Probleme, gell?
Ja. [Lacht]
[Musik]
Boah, die ist voll scharf. [Güni lacht]
Aber es hat Spaß gemacht, das Ding zu drehen.
GÜNI: Ja, mach doch mehr rein.
MURAT: Nein. Und zwar: Wenn es zu scharf ist,
kriegt ihr die Schärfe raus, indem ihr Salz verwendet.
Wusstest du das eigentlich?
GÜNI: Ich habe mal gehört, Honig.
MURAT: Ehrlich? [Güni bejaht]
[Musik]
GÜNI: Doch!
MURAT: Ehrlich jetzt? [Güni bejaht]
Du musst eins verstehen, Die Schärfe ist ein Schmerz, okay?
Salz ist auch ein Schm…
GÜNI: Stehst du auf Schmerz?
MURAT: [Lacht] Ja, ich stehe auf Schmerzen.
GÜNI: Da kann man noch was machen.
Pass auf!
Ja,
MURAT: Ja… [Doing] Es ist immer noch scharf. Boah! [Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Mach ein bisschen Zucker oder Honig rein!
MURAT: Honig?
GÜNI: Das hilft.
MURAT: Ehrlich jetzt?
Oder Milch, Milch! [Lacht]
GÜNI: Nein, mach ein bisschen Zucker rein.
MURAT: Nein, wir lassen es einfach drin
[Doing] und sagen den Zuschauern, es hat geschmeckt.
GÜNI: Ja, das ist Pizza Teufel.
MURAT: Ja! Pizza Teufel ist scharf.
Das heißt Diavolo, nicht Teufel! Das ist wieder…
Ein Italiener wäre jetzt sauer auf dich.
GÜNI: Okay. Ich sage: Pizza Murat.
MURAT: Ja.
Ah! Ich habe eine ganz, ganz tolle Idee.
Weißt du, was wir machen? Ich mache ein bisschen Schmand rein. Ja!
GÜNI: Dann wird die Sauce rosa. Wie sieht das denn aus?
MURAT: Das ist nicht schlimm. Das ist toll. [Güni verneint]
Dann ist die Pizza Diabolo rosa – rosé.
GÜNI: Rosé ist Französisch, oder? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Also das war wirklich der Fehler:
Ich hatte so Spaß am Pfeffer, dass es mir zu scharf geworden ist.
Aber das ist das Coole am Kochen: Man lernt immer dazu,
wenn der Murat kocht, was man falsch machen kann.
Ich habe es reingemacht. [Güni lacht]
[Musik]
So, funktioniert! Einrühren.
Du wirst gleich merken, Güni.
Aber du hast recht:
Die Farbe verändert sich. Es wird leicht rosa.
GÜNI: Ist rosa deine Farbe? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Und deine ist gleich rot.
GÜNI: Ja?
MURAT: Ja.
[Bedrohliche Musik] Hattest du schon mal plötzliches Nasenbluten?
So zufällig? [Güni verneint]
Nicht? Kann vorkommen!
Jetzt nehmen wir hier dieser Pfanne…
Mach aus!
Mach aus? Ach so! [Beide lachen]
Also wir holen Paprika raus.
GÜNI: Was kommt jetzt?
MURAT: Was machen wir jetzt?
GÜNI: Nix.
MURAT: Jetzt machen wir es so, wie du eine Pizza belegen würdest.
Du musst jetzt anders denken, Güni.
Ich meine, du hast im Denken sowieso Probleme
und anders schon gar nicht.
Deswegen: Wir machen es jetzt einfach anders.
GÜNI: Wie?
MURAT: Okay.
Also, erstmal probieren wir die Sauce - warte mal kurz! -
ob sie jetzt besser geworden ist. Warte!
[Trommelwirbel] Ja. Die Schärfe ist ein bisschen weg,
muss man ehrlich sagen.
Noch ein bisschen Salz.
Jetzt haben wir die Sauce gekocht
Und jetzt heizen wir den Ofen schon einmal vor.
Und dann nehmen wir Ober-/Unterhitze. Genau.
Oder vielleicht habt ihr auch 4D-Heißluft.
4D-Heißluft ist auch eine coole Geschichte.
Ober-/Unterhitze, 200°C und Start.
Jetzt nehmen wir die gleiche Form.
Jetzt tun wir die Paprika, die wir rausgeholt haben, wieder rein.
Genau, jetzt schichten wir es richtig schön.
Güni, genau - schön schichten.
Genau. So.
GÜNI: Zwiebeln?
MURAT: Dann nehmen wir die Zwiebeln. Genau.
Tun wir jetzt auch -
Genau so,
wie du eine Pizza zu Hause bei normalen Menschen belegen würdest.
Aber wir sind ja - du bist ja kein normaler Mensch, gell?
Du bist doch irgendwo zwischen Mensch und Tier hängengeblieben.
Also bei einem Wombat.
Erst waren es die Affen und dann der Wombat
und dann kam erst der Homo sapiens, der intelligente Mensch.
Ich.
GÜNI: Ganz vorne war der Murat. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Jetzt haben wir hier -
GÜNI: Mais.
MURAT: Genau, Mais können wir auch dazu geben.
Und dann nehmt ihr einfach, so viel ihr möchtet.
Ihr könnt wirklich auch Champignons nehmen - was ihr möchtet.
GÜNI: Je nach Geschmack.
MURAT: Je nach Geschmack. Genau.
Was ich euch nicht empfehlen würde, weil -
Was ich nicht empfehlen würde, ist Folgendes zu machen:.
Jetzt wirklich die Salami drauf zu machen, weil sie dann versinkt.
Das sieht nachher nicht schön aus.
Die machen wir ganz zum Schluss drauf. Ich sage euch auch ganz genau, wann.
Jetzt nehmen wir den Käse, den ich geschnibbelt habe.
Darf ich?
[Musik]
Oh! Guck mal, Güni!
[Murat singt]
GÜNI: Kannst du italienisch?
MURAT: Ja: Ciao!
Pasta.
GÜNI: Weiter!
MURAT: Bella.
Piano.
GÜNI: Das hast du schön gesagt.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Oh mein Gott!
GÜNI: Das hast du schön gesagt.
MURAT: Ja.
So, jetzt machen wir auch die Mozzarella schön drauf.
Und da könnt ihr richtig schön drapieren, nennt sich das dann.
Wusstest du das?
Drapieren?
GÜNI: Ja. Kommt von Trapez. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: So.
GÜNI: Mach den Teller noch leer.
MURAT: Jawoll.
GÜNI: Mach das wie kleine Teufelchen, mit deinen Fingern.
Ja.
MURAT: Ich weiß, dass sich manche Italiener denken: Was machen die 2 da gerade?
Es ist mir vollkommen bewusst.
Aber es ist einfach einfach so.
Und es geht auch normalerweise wirklich schnell,
wenn ich nicht jeden Schritt kleinschrittig erklären müsste.
Ich muss nämlich alle Kochschritte didaktisch so runterbrechen,
dass es kleine Kinder und der Güni verstehen. Ja, deswegen!.
So, jetzt haben wir hier die Sauce.
Jetzt nehme ich hier die Tomatensoße.
Und bei der Tomatensauce ist es ganz wichtig:
Guckt, dass es nicht außen drankommt,
also hauptsächlich immer so einen Rand lassen.
Also die Tomatensoße nicht in den Rand schütten.
GÜNI: 1 cm Rand lassen.
MURAT: Genau, 1 cm Rand und schön die Tomatensauce drauf.
So.
GÜNI: Wie viele mm sind 1 cm?
MURAT: 10. [Quiz-Musik]
GÜNI: Und wie viele mm sind 100 ml?
MURAT: 100.
GÜNI: Und 1.000? [Lacht]
MURAT: 1.000.
Du bist so blöd! [Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Noch so ein bisschen verteilen.
MURAT: Genau.
GÜNI: Vorsichtig.
MURAT: Aber nicht in den Rand.
Genau, nicht arg in den Rand,
weil sonst läuft oben die Pizza aus.
GÜNI: Du hast das Know-how nicht, bei so feinen Sachen.
MURAT: Ich hau… Ich haue auch gleich.
Know-how!
GÜNI: Ich habe das Know-how.
Das heißt, du sollst nicht hauen. [Beide lacht]
Das sieht gut aus.
MURAT: So, der Teig ist aufgegangen,
so wie der Güni auch schon.
Und jetzt bearbeiten wir schon einmal den Teig.
Hab ich recht?
Güni, machst du das? Weil mein Finger tut voll weh.
Tut echt weh, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Echt!
GÜNI: Sieht auch nicht gut aus.
MURAT: So. Aua!
So, jetzt holen wir den Teig raus.
Jetzt zeig, was du drauf hast, Güni!
Schön ausrollen!
GÜNI: Ein bisschen einmehlen.
MURAT: Genau.
Du wurdest als Kind auch immer eingemehlt, gell?
GÜNI: Du eingefettet. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Kannst dich es nicht ein bisschen wie Luigi oder Marioa machen?.
So ein bisschen mit der Hand.
So ein bisschen zackzack.
So ein bisschen ziehen und drücken,
dass es ein bisschen professionell aussieht.
GÜNI: Ich muss erstmal umdrehen.
Luigi, du!
[Musik]
Da fehlen die Dings.
MURAT: Was fehlt?
GÜNI: Die Griffe.
MURAT: Was für Griffe?
GÜNI: Ich kenne nur eine Holznudel, also Nudelholz,
MURAT: Nudelholz!
[Beide lachen]
GÜNI: Du machst mich nervös.
MURAT: Und du machst mich blöd.
GÜNI: Nein, nein! Du warst das vorher schon.
MURAT: Es haben sich gerade drei Italiener von der Brücke geschmissen,
nachdem sie gesehen haben, wie du den Teig ausrollst.
Weißt du das?
Ich entschuldige mich wirklich von ganzem Herzen.
beim italienischen Volk wegen Güni.
Es tut mir wirklich leid. [Beide lachen]
Maria! Genau, Maria, unsere Kollegin aus Mannheim.
Maria, wenn du das siehst: Ich kann nichts dafür.
Wirklich. Sorry!
So, jetzt stechen wir den Teig ein. [Aufschrei]
Nicht einstechen! Wir stechen ihn nicht ein!
Wir stechen nicht ein!
Ich wollte nur testen.
Genau, jetzt pass auf!
Jetzt musst mir einen Gefallen tun.
GÜNI: Das ist das, was mich so fertig macht. Ihr lacht.
MURAT: Genau. Das ist jetzt die Kunst.
Genau. Hier drüber legen. Pass auf!
Wir machen es zu zweit.
GÜNI: Das passt?
MURAT: Ja.
So, an den Rändern runterdrücken, Güni.
Genau. Schön an den Rändern runterdrücken.
Hast du es gemacht?
Das sieht nachher aus wie eine Pastete.
So, jetzt haben wir hier noch diesen Kamm.
Dieser Kamm ist auch gleichzeitig…
Von meiner Frau,
so ein Torten-Dekorations-Zeug.
Keine Ahnung, was - sie backt einfach.
So, und das hier nehmen wir und stechen ein.
Warum stechen wir ein, lieber Güni?
Weißt du Bescheid?
GÜNI: Nicht zu viel. [Doing] Nimm die andere Seite.
MURAT: Ja.
GÜNI: Die da. [Lacht]
MURAT: Oh!
GÜNI: Nicht so viel!
MURAT: Sag den Zuschauern lieber, warum ich einsteche!
GÜNI: Dass es keine Blasen gibt.
MURAT: Genau.
Güni, in Waghäusel nennt man dich auch den Stecher.
[Güni lacht].
Machst du das?
GÜNI: Ja, du hast das doch jetzt schon gemacht. [Murat stimmt zu]
Noch einmal?
MURAT: Genau. Alles klar.
Jetzt nehmen wir diese Pizza-Form.
und lassen sie ungefähr für 10 Minuten im Backofen braten.
[Doing] 20 Min.? 20 Min.!
Jetzt nehmen wir diese Form
und tun sie ungefähr für 20 Min. in den Backofen.
GÜNI: Bei?
MURAT: Bei 200°C.
Richtig. Genau. 20 min und 200°C.
Hilfst du mir, Güni?
GÜNI: Verbrenn dich nicht, gell?
MURAT: Danke, Güni, dass du dir solche Sorgen um mich machst.
In den nächsten 20 Min. räumen wir und machen alles sauber.
Und dann zeigen wir euch, was dann passiert.
Stell mal die Zeit ein!
[Musik und Uhr]
So, jetzt hat gebimmelt,
d.h., die Pizza ist fertig.
Ich hole sie jetzt raus.
GÜNI: Der erste Gang.
MURAT: Diabolo.
So, jetzt wird sie…
Jetzt wird sie….
Pass auf, Güni. Das ist jetzt saumäßig wichtig.
Das ist so wie bei Siegfried und Roy.
Jetzt Trommelwirbel! Ich brauche Trommelwirbel. [Trommelwirbel]
Ja. Jetzt legst du es drauf.
Genau. Ein Backpapier nehmen, ein Backblech nehmen.
GÜNI: Kann ich einzeln machen.
MURAT: Genau.
GÜNI: Sonst kapierst du das nicht.
MURAT: Bist du aufgeregt? Kann das sein? [Güni verneint]
Doch, ich merke das gerade.
GÜNI: Pass auf, das ist heiß. Schnell, gell?
MURAT: Ja, jetzt nehme ich das Ding. [Trommelwirbel]
Ich habe voll Angst, dass es… Ich habe voll Angst, dass es…
[Ahhhh!] Kannst du das machen? [Güni verneint]
Bitte, mach du doch!
GÜNI: Jetzt mach doch!
MURAT: Jetzt mach doch du! Doch, komm! Mach!
GÜNI: Ich will doch lachen.
MURAT: Nein, ich will nicht lachen.
GÜNI: Du willst nur, dass es mir passiert.
MURAT: Nein.
[Trommelwirbel] Jetzt mach!
[Trommelwirbel] Jetzt mach! [Trommelwirbel]
Oh! Wahnsinn! [Jubel]
GÜNI: Silberpfeil.
MURAT: Ja, Silberpfeil.
Der graue Star vielleicht, der graue Star vielleicht.
So, jetzt kommt es du darauf an, ob wir es richtig oder falsch gemacht haben.
Sehen wir jetzt gleich.
[Musik]
GÜNI: Ganz heiß!
MURAT: Aber bin ich froh, dass du kein Kind auf die Welt bringst!
Wirklich!
Brauchst du die PTA?
GÜNI: Das hängt irgendwie.
MURAT: Nein, es hängt nicht fest.
GÜNI: Doch. Jetzt kommt's.
MURAT: Jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
[Musik]
[Jubel] Bäm! Bam!
So, es hat funktioniert.
Wir sind aber - jetzt denkt ihr vielleicht, wir sind fertig,
aber wir sind nicht fertig.
Und zwar ist es jetzt so ziemlich lätschig.
Also so richtig lätschig.
Und jetzt möchten wir es knusprig haben. Der Boden ist richtig dick.
Jetzt nehmen wir noch hier Salamischeiben.
GÜNI: Das kannst du noch auskratzen. Alles raus!
MURAT: Nein.
GÜNI: Doch, alles drauf. Guck mal, da ist Dings drin.
MURAT: Ach so, ja, machen wir das jetzt ganz kurz.
Jetzt haben wir noch sinnlos zwei Sachen dreckig gemacht.
GÜNI: Ist doch egal. Wir müssen es nicht sauber machen.
Wir haben unsere Leute. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Jetzt nehmen wir das.
GÜNI: Jetzt weiß ich, woher das kommt.
MURAT: Was?
GÜNI: Du hast zu viel probiert.
MURAT: Zack! Und deswegen erst die Salami zum Schluss drauf.
So! So! So!
[Musik]
GÜNI: Ist das Rindersalami?
MURAT: Ja, das ist halal.
Sag mal!
GÜNI: Halau! Helau!
MURAT: Ja, genau.
So, jetzt nehmen wir da
und tun's nochmal 20 Min. in den Backofen.
Dann wird sie nämlich richtig crusty oben.
Und genau das möchten wir haben.
GÜNI: Was wird das?
MURAT: Crusty.
Kennst du nicht Krusty, den Clown? Kennst du es nicht? [Güni verneint]
Okay.
[Musik und Uhr]
Halt mal das Blech!
GÜNI: Ist es heiß? [Murat bejaht]
Soll ich heben?
MURAT: Ja. Nur einen Finger drauf.
[Musik]
Zieh mal weg!
So, jetzt müssen wir die Pizza von dem Papier runter kriegen, Güni.
Wie machen wir das jetzt?
GÜNI: Nimm doch einen Heber!
MURAT: Ah, Heber, genau. Wir nehmen einen Heber. [Güni lacht]
Ich habe andere Idee. Okay? Ich habe eine andere Idee.
Ja. Ich rolle das einfach drunter weg.
GÜNI: Halt. Halt. Ich halte es fest.
MURAT: Nein. Pass auf, pass auf!
Pass auf! Das ist wie beim Zauberer.
GÜNI: Guck mal! Du hast alles versaut.
MURAT: Ja, aber es sah cooler aus als… [Güni stimmt zu]
So, jetzt müssen wir jemanden holen, der unparteiisch ist.
GÜNI: Ich.
MURAT: Den wir nicht manipulieren können
und der seine Wahrheit sagt.
GÜNI: Ich.
MURAT: Nein, du nicht. Du bist parteiisch, korrupt und alles.
Ja, bist noch korrupter als Sepp Blatter
und das geht sehr, sehr schwer.
Warum bist du eigentlich im Olympischen Komitee?
Die sind alle korrupt.
Also holen wir jemanden, auf den wir notfalls auch verzichten könnten,
unseren Azubi Max.
[Alle lachen]
MAX:
Hallo.
MURAT: Hier ist der Max.
Max, ich muss dir was sagen.
Er kommt aus Franken.
Ich habe letztes Mal gesagt, dass der Max aus Bayern kommt.
Und da hab ich voll ein Shitstorm bekommen.
MAX:
Ist ja eigentlich Bayern.
GÜNI: Es gehört ja zu Bayern.
MURAT: Herzogenaurach. Ja, da, wo Adidas herkommt.
Warum hast du eigentlich nicht bei Adidas gearbeitet?
MAX:
[Doing] Ich bin da nicht reingekommen.
MURAT: Na ja. Gut zu wissen. Danke schön.
GÜNI: Hier komm jeder rein.
[Alle lachen]
MURAT: Wenn ich euch fragt, warum der Güni hier ist:
Der ist auch nirgends reingekommen.
GÜNI: Hier kommt jeder rein?
MURAT: Ja, so ist es.
GÜNI: Bewerbt euch einfach.
Auch wenn ihr nichts könnt.
MURAT: Man merkt es ja.
Du musst echt ehrlich sein.
MAX:
Was ist das für eine Pizza?
MURAT: Wie nennen wir die Pizza?
Upside down. Genau.
Wir haben sie andersherum gemacht.
GÜNI: Diabolo.
MURAT: Diabolo Upside down, okay?
MAX:
Okay
MURAT: Wir haben die Pizza andersherum gemacht
und dann hat sie trotzdem wie eine Pizza ausgesehen.
Wahnsinn, oder?
MAX:
Ihr habt sie dann einfach wieder umgedreht?
MURAT: Genau in der Pfanne.
GÜNI: Aber ehrlich sein, wie gut das schmeckt.
MURAT: Ehrlich, jetzt ohne Spaß!
GÜNI: Denk dran: Dein Arbeitsplatz ist in Gefahr.
MURAT: Aber jetzt wirklich ehrlich.
GÜNI: Ehrlich sein.
MURAT: Weil wenn es nicht schmeckt,
ist das sowieso nicht unser Kanal.
GÜNI: Wir wollen nicht drohen, gell?
MURAT: Ja. Okay.
MAX:
Kommt gut, wenn man das mit einem großen Messer macht.
MURAT: Ja. So! Und zwar ist es das Murat Knife.
Das ist wirklich nur für…
Wir verkaufen es wirklich…
Ist echt so: Im Shop steht es drinnen: Nur für Männer. Ja.
[Musik]
Ja, ist so!
Ich kann aber nichts dafür. Das ist einfach so.
GÜNI: Warum ist es klein und pummelig?
Du bist auch nicht klein und pummelig. [Lacht]
MURAT: So, dann fangen wir an.
Max, ganz, ganz ehrlich, okay?
GÜNI: Wie viele sind wir denn? Zwei, vier, sechs.
MURAT: Sechs Leute sind wir.
GÜNI: Du kriegst nichts.
MURAT: Wir haben ja genug Veganer hier. Die kriegen nichts.
GÜNI: Wer ist Veganer?
MURAT: Max, probier!
Bist du mehr der Randtyp oder mehr der Mittetyp?
MAX:
Das ist mir eigentlich gleich.
MURAT: Ehrlich? Okay.
GÜNI: Vielleicht gibst du dem Max einen Teller.
MURAT: Ach so, ich gebe dir einen Teller, Max. Einen Moment!
GÜNI: Max, wir sind Deutsche.
MURAT: Ich habe es gehört.
Du bist einfach nur…
GÜNI: Probier, Max!
Max, denke an deinen Job!
MAX:
Heiß!
MURAT: Ist heiß, gell?
Ha ja, bei 220°C. Wieso haust du die Pizza… ?
GÜNI: Wieso 220? 10 % Aufschlag, gell?
MAX:
Schon würzig relativ… Also ein bisschen Schärfe ist dabei.
GÜNI: Ja, Pfeffer.
MAX:
Ich weiß nicht. Und zwar wurde die Pizza gesponsert
MURAT: vom Pfefferkontor in München. [Alle lachen]
MAX:
Das ist aber schief gegangen.
MURAT: Ja, es ist ein bisschen Pfeffer…
Pfeffer war einfach im Angebot,
MAX:
aber es schmeckt eher nach Chili als nach Pfeffer.
MURAT: Ja, ja, weil es… [Modemgeräusche]
Ja, weil auch Chili drin ist.
MAX:
Ja, okay. Schmeckt gut.
MURAT: Wirklich jetzt? [Max bejaht]
Wenn wir jetzt Pizza am Abend…
GÜNI: Wer wir mal probieren?
MURAT: Ja, wen haben wir noch?
Tolga, komm auch noch her! Tolga, komm her!
Tolga darf auch noch probieren.
[Musik]
So, Tolga, Rand oder Mitte?
GÜNI: Teller!
MURAT: Nutella.
GÜNI: Nicht Nutella.
Teller.
MURAT: So, okay?
Aber bitte: Ich weiß, ihr werdet bezahlt,
aber sagt trotzdem die Wahrheit!
GÜNI: Ja, denkt an euren Job, gell?
MURAT: Wie schmeckt's? Heiß!
TOLGA:
Geil?
MURAT: Ja, echt?
TOLGA:
Voll saftig.
MAX:
Es ist voll viel drauf.
MURAT: Aber wenn du einen Netflix-Abend machen würdest
und dann die Schmuddel-Filme anschaust…
GÜNI: Was für Filme?
MURAT: Stummfilme!
GÜNI: Ich habe Schmuddel-filme verstanden. [Max stimmt zu]
MURAT: Da merkt man, was du wieder im Kopf hast. Wahnsinn! Wahnsinn!
Nein, es ist wirklich einfach, weil ihr…
GÜNI: Der kann noch nicht richtig Deutsch.
MURAT: Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Wer kann kein Deutsch?
GÜNI: Niemand.
MURAT: [Deutsche Hymne] Ich bin hier geboren, in Balingen. 30.9.1989.
[Grillengeräusche]
Balingen, Schwäbische Alb.
GÜNI: Ach, da haben sie dich immer den Berg runtergrollt, gell?
Als Kind schon.
MURAT: Aber ihr würdest es nachmachen, oder?
MAX:
Ja.
MURAT: Seid ihr stolz auch auf mich? [Max und Tolga bejahen)
Probieren wir auch?
GÜNI: Mach mal dünne Stücke.
MURAT: Ja. Wir machen jetzt dünne Stücke,
weil wir tun jetzt grad Ding…
GÜNI: Für dich ist es.
Teller, nimm einen Teller!
MURAT: Nutella.
GÜNI: Josh, du auch? Ja, oder?
MURAT: Wollt ihr es alle probieren?
GÜNI: Du auch.
MURAT: Aber ihr wisst, dass er mit seinen Händen drin war?
GÜNI: Ich nicht.
JOSH: Dann nehme ich keins.
GÜNI: Ich war nicht mit der…
Iss langsam!
Sei nicht so gierig!
Du bist doch die Raupe. Du hast zu mir gesagt,
du wärst die Raupe Nimmersatt. Weißt du das noch?
Wo wir Döner essen waren?
Doch, da hast du mir gesagt, ob ich sie Nimmersatt kenne.
MURAT: Aber wirklich…
GÜNI: Ein großes oder ein kleines?
JUTTA:
Ich hätte gern ein kleines.
MURAT: Jetzt weißt du aber schon, dass wir die Bilder….
Wir haben vergessen, Bilder zu machen. Wir sind so dumm.
GÜNI: Was heißt wir?
MURAT: Du und ich.
GÜNI: Wer isst denn da schon? Habe ich was gegessen?
MURAT: Ja… ja, aber….
GÜNI: Ich weiß, dass wir Bilder brauchen.
MURAT: Ja, du bist dumm und ich auch.
GÜNI: Nee, du bist gefräßig.
MURAT: Ja, okay.
GÜNI: Und dumm.
MURAT: Ach so, ach ja. Dumm und gefräßig. Das ist immer gefährlich.
Ja, wir müssen es nochmal machen.
Wir haben vergessen, die Bilder zu machen.
GÜNI: Josh, groß oder klein?
JOSH: Groß!
GÜNI: Geh doch mal aus dem Weg! Du kriegst nichts mehr!
MURAT: Hammer! Nachmachen!
Abonniert den Kanal oder auch nicht!
Ist nicht unserer. Ja, so.
Hatet die anderen! Wir können nichts dafür.
GÜNI: [Lacht] "Hatet die anderen!"
Großes?
MURAT: Und kommentiert! Schreibt was in die Kommentare!
Ich könnt auch was gegen Güni schreiben. Ist es vollkommen egal.
GÜNI: Ja, ich bin das gewohnt.
MURAT: Der ist das sowieso egal,
weil er den ganzen Tag Tierfilme mit Kugelfischen anschaut.
Also Tschüss. Macht's gut. Tschüss, Güni.
GÜNI: Hey, aufräumen noch!
[Musik]